[Música]
la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu nancy pelosi se
reunió con la presidenta de taiwán a
quien aseguró que no retrocederá ante
las amenazas chinas el ejército taiwanés
aumentó su nivel de alerta luego del
anuncio de beijing de ejercicios
militares en respuesta a la llegada a
taipei de la demócrata
un grupo de cocaleros bolivianos se
enfrentó por segundo día consecutivo a
la policía en la paz los cultivadores
exigen el cierre de un mercado de coca
para el el val estatal que fue abierto
recientemente tenemos reporte de nuestra
corresponsal
y miles de estudiantes panameños
volvieron a las aulas tras el acuerdo
del gobierno con los maestros que puso
fin a una huelga de casi un mes en el
país caribeño son 21 puntos de acuerdo
que incluyen un 5.5 por ciento del pib
destinado a la educación
estas son las noticias de américa en
france 24 mi nombre es ángela gómez
comenzamos
nancy pelosi se reunió en taipei con la
presidenta de taiwanés tsai in wen y le
aseguró que eeuu no abandonará a taiwán
y que la isla es un ejemplo para el
mundo repitió que visitó el territorio
en son de paz ante las amenazas de
beijing que ordenó ejercicios militares
tras el aterrizaje de la demócrata bomba
la presidenta taiwanesa condecoró a
pelosi con la orden de las nubes
propicias por su apoyo y aseguró que su
país no cederá ante las amenazas chinas
el ejército de la isla elevó su nivel de
alerta escuchamos a pelosi
señora presidenta creo que es importante
recordar a algunos e informar a otros de
cómo estamos aquí
hace 43 años con la ley de relación con
taiwán eeuu hizo una promesa fundamental
de estar siempre con taiwán
sobre esta base sólida construimos una
asociación prospera basada en nuestros
valores compartidos de auto poder y
autodeterminación enfocada en nuestros
intereses de seguridad mutuos en la
región y en todo el mundo
cultivadores de coca en bolivia se
enfrentaron a la policía de la paz
exigiendo el cierre de un controvertido
mercado de coca en la ciudad hubo
intercambio de gases lacrimógenos y
dinamita casera por el establecimiento
que los cocaleros consideran ilegal la
protesta es producto de una disputa
prolongada entre dos grupos los
productores de los yungas que tomaron
las calles de la paz y un grupo
respaldado por el gobierno la ampliación
no nos la daban previamente nuestra
corresponsal en la paz mery vaca
por segundo día consecutivo la ciudad de
la paz ha sido escenario de fuertes
enfrentamientos entre la policía y los
productores de coca de los yungas que
están agrupados en una asociación que se
denomina a de coca esta asociación
protesta en contra de la apertura de un
mercado paralelo de venta de coca en la
ciudad que está ubicado en el barrio de
villa el carmen ellos aseguran que el
único mercado legal que debería ser
reconocido por las autoridades es el
mercado que está en villa fátima por eso
se han dirigido en marchas para pedir el
cierre del otro mercado del mercado
paralelo sin embargo los manifestantes
aseguran que este mercado paralelo está
manejado por un sector afín al gobierno
de luís arce y por tanto está
fuertemente custodiado por la policía en
ese contexto los efectivos han
reaccionado con gases lacrimógenos en
contra de los cocaleros que arremetían
para acercarse a ese mercado usando
petardos en este marco del conflicto se
ha producido un herido un periodista ha
resultado lesionado por el efecto de un
petardo y un día antes un productor de
coca también ha sido herido por efecto
de esta refriega hay que recordar que el
conflicto de adepcoca ya es de larga
data el año pasado más o menos en
septiembre se ha producido también duros
enfrentamientos en la ciudad de la paz
sin que se haya resuelto el conflicto de
hecho en esta jornada los productores de
adepcoca han anunciado la llegada de más
productores desde la zona de los yungas
para sostener este conflicto hasta
lograr sus objetivos además han pedido
la renuncia del ministro de desarrollo
rural y tierras remy gonzález en panamá
a miles de estudiantes volvieron a clase
después de una huelga de maestros que se
prolongó durante casi un mes los
profesores demandaban más inversión en
la educación además de la congelación de
los precios de los productos de la
canasta familiar y del combustible
informa manuel a cano un optimista
regreso más de 840.000 estudiantes
volvieron a las escuelas públicas en
panamá luego de una huelga de docentes
que se prolongó durante casi un mes
bueno me siento contenta porque los
niños regresaron era verdad que yo
tenían que regresar a sus aulas y
aprender más y bueno finalmente se logró
lo que estaban buscando los maestros
como los padres de familia que estaban
peleando en la calle sus derechos
cuadernos listos y útiles en la mesa se
pueden ver en más de 3000 aulas que
habían permanecido vacías mientras los
maestros demandaban al gobierno
modificaciones en el sistema educativo
además de una rebaja en la canasta
básica en los medicamentos y en el
combustible los docentes dejaron las
calles y se sentaron a negociar con el
gobierno tras la firma de un documento
pactado entre ambas partes volvieron a
sus labores el texto contempla 21
acuerdos de los puntos planteados por
los educadores
uno de sus principales el gobierno
asignará un 55 por ciento del pib en
2022 para la educación y un 6% en 2024
es decir cerca de 1200 millones de
dólares estamos conscientes de que esos
niños también son hijos de docentes y
hoy por hoy le doy gracias a dios que no
se llevó más tiempo del que se llevó
para lograrlo todo lo que se logró
en el último mes las calles panameñas se
llenaron de las protestas más intensas
en décadas el sector educativo fue uno
de sus principales promotores al que se
sumaron sindicatos gremios
organizaciones indígenas y la sociedad
civil las manifestaciones derivaron en
que el gobierno de laurentino cortizo un
congelará el precio del combustible y de
algunos productos de la canasta básica
además de un plan de austeridad que
reduce en 10% la planilla estatal y los
gastos de los ministros los ciudadanos
de kansas en estados unidos votaron en
rechazo de una enmienda constitucional
estatal que buscaba remover el derecho
al aborto de la constitución el
referendo es una gran victoria por los
derechos reproductivos en el país de
tras la caída de roe versus wait que
defendía la interrupción voluntaria del
embarazo a nivel federal la votación ha
sido considerada un indicador temprano
de si el derecho al aborto motivará a
los votantes en las elecciones
intermedias de noviembre y en kansas se
representa un fracaso para los
legisladores republicanos que buscaban
aprobar severas restricciones al aborto
la policía de nicaragua ese día por
orden del presidente daniel ortega al
párroco de una iglesia de matagalpa esto
después de ordenar el lunes el cierre de
seis emisoras adscritas a esta diócesis
nuestro corresponsal en centroamérica
andrés suárez jaramillo nos contó cómo
se ha desarrollado el asedio con lo que
está sucediendo actualmente en nicaragua
no es una novedad que el gobierno de
daniel ortega y su esposa rosario
murillo también vicepresidenta estén
accediendo diferentes medios de
comunicación
encarcelando a los directores
poniéndolos fuera del aire lo que
resulta peculiar y particular es que lo
hagan con radios tan pequeñas
comunitarias rurales como las radios
católicas de diferentes municipios en
este caso de uno de los municipios al
norte de nicaragua llamado se bajo en
este momento un grupo de policías
mantiene el asedio alrededor de una
iglesia la iglesia de el niño jesús de
praga y ya se adentró el cura oscar
vallejos que se encuentra uriel vallejos
perdón que se encuentra incomunicado
completamente física del exterior y lo
hacen para mostrar su fuerza horas antes
esto sucedió hace el asedio comenzó 24
horas atrás cuando un grupo de
antimotines irrumpió a la fuerza
lanzando gases lacrimógenos también
disparos al aire dejando heridos por
delante solamente para llevarse los
equipos transmisores de esta radio
católica horas antes de este hecho el
instituto de telecomunicaciones
nicaragüense telcor había decretado que
se cerrarían otras seis otras cinco
radios católicas de la diócesis de
matagalpa y aquí hacemos una reflexión
un hincapié quien es el obispo que
detenta esta diócesis es el señor el
monseñor rolando álvarez uno de los más
acérrimos críticos del gobierno de
ortega quien a través de estas radios ha
pedido incesantemente que se liberen los
190 presos políticos que desde el año
2018 cuando comenzaron las masivas
protestas en nicaragua pues están en las
cárceles todo tipo de opositores desde
directores de medios de
son ex candidatos a la presidencia
etcétera y es por eso que en
contrapartida daniel ortega llama a los
obispos de nicaragua como terroristas y
golpistas un aeropuerto de guarulhos
casi vacío presenció el regreso de la
selección de brasil que ganó su cuarta
copa en américa en fila y la octava en
su historia sin aficionados sin
autoridades y apenas con un puñado de
periodistas la vuelta a casa desde viña
y compañía quedó en deuda con el fútbol
mostrado por el equipo a lo largo del
torneo 20 goles a favor y ninguno en
contra más los cupos al mundial y los
juegos olímpicos fue el saldo de las
brasileñas en la final jugada en
colombia
síganos en france 24 y en france 24
punto coma
[Música]